calma en el aeropuerto internacional de
kiev a pesar del creciente número de
países que piden a sus ciudadanos y el
personal de sus embajadas que abandonen
ucrania países como eeuu reino unido
canadá israel y australia han hecho el
llamado ante el riesgo de una agresión
rusa ayer ordenamos la salida de la
mayoría de los estadounidenses que aún
se encuentran en la embajada de eeuu de
quiere el regreso de una acción militar
rusa de lo suficientemente alto y la
amenaza de lo suficientemente inminente
como para que esto sea lo más prudente
eeuu al igual que australia y otros
países occidentales trasladará
temporalmente sus operaciones a levy
cerca de la frontera con polonia
mining tenemos tres miembros del
personal restantes y se les ha ordenado
que se trasladen alevín a countries
action del pib porque al igual lo
hicieron los otros países de la alianza
de los cinco ojos el actuar unilateral
autocrático de rusia de estar amenazando
e intimidando ucrania es algo que es
inaceptable excepto ucrania rechaza las
acciones que ha habido en el pánico y
ofreció mantener el espacio aéreo
abierto pese a las advertencias de la
casa blanca de que una invasión podría
darse en cualquier momento